new hair new chris
yep kris jenner is changing up her
signature dude
boy
of course the momager is known for her
short pixie cut but now she's rocking a
longer bob instead complete with some
wispy bangs the mom of six debuted her
new look ahead of daughter kylie
jenner's cosmetics launch party for her
latest collab with her sister kendall
and at the event the beauty mogul filmed
her proud mama giving a speech and we
just gotta say chris's new locks are on
point
just not only as sisters but as
friends best friends
business women i couldn't be prouder
than anyone in my entire life i feel
blessed but this isn't the first time
chris has traded in her iconic look for
something different
this is the new me
mom
hey him
what
is going on
do you like it
i think it looks really great are you
sure
yeah
yeah remember when she briefly tried out
an icy blonde wig to match with kim i
love that as for chris's latest change
up well we'll just have to wait and see
how long it lasts
tune in because you never know what's
going to happen and speaking of tuning
in earlier in the day chris was still
rocking her iconic do during a stop by
the ellen degeneres show where she
opened up about what's to come on the
family's new hulu reality series we've
been doing this for 15 years now which
is a blessing but also a little scary
and then of course the minute we start
filming a million things happen yeah
kylie's having a baby courtney's dating
travis uh barker and gets engaged and i
mean it just kept go and then kim gets
snl and i mean every single day there
was this either drama or something crazy
going on or somebody having a baby
somebody getting divorced somebody i
mean it was it was nutty one of the
biggest things in her life is about to
happen and courtney has no idea
[Music]
i am very excited to have another baby
it's really hard with kanye tristan and
i are complicated trust takes time i'm
so over there scott i'm out but at the
end of the day the reality star is just
happy to have the cameras rolling again
and have her family spending lots of
time together i missed it i realized how
much i really missed it and being with
the kids every day we're together but
it's just different never go against the
family
never go against the family
[Music]